what up space fam golson here from anime
opera and i'm back at it again i heard
you loud and clear on the luffy's new
bounty video and so here i am with a
similar video breakdown of zorro's new
bounty and how it got there channel
power came with it and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
videos like this one on the channel be a
smashing power king and not a passing
odochi if you haven't joined the nakama
by subscribing and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one-piece videos and
updates and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all as
with the luffy video first we'll break
down zoro's bounty journey zorro had
less bounties than luffy and his first
one appeared during chapter 213 after
his defeat of mr 1 aka the killer dos
bones warlord crocodile's strongest
fighter now since he's not the captain
we can never expect zoro's bounty to
surpass luffy's but he is from the
beginning established as the first mate
and second strongest fighter in the
straw hat crew compared to luffy's new
100 million bounty after alabasta zorros
is 60 million and even though luffy will
inevitably get the spotlight in the
media's eyes and thus get a higher
bounty and focus 60 million is still
really good with this zorro doubled
luffy's old bounty of 30 million and
shot way ahead of old main antagonists
luffy already beat like arlon who had a
20 million bounty mr one's vivre card
revealed his bounty to be 75 million but
i'm guessing this is a figure only
established later on in the story
because we only got it later and since
crocodile's former bounty before he
became a warlord was 81 million not that
much higher and his new post warlord
bounty has yet to be revealed also we
can assume that zoro would have shot
well past that mark if he defeated mr
one while he had a 75 million bounty at
this point zoro had a bounty that was 60
percent of luffy's own now let's discuss
the post and his lobby attack bounties
after defeating rob luchi the strongest
member in cp9 history and declaring war
on the world government luffy's bounty
jumped up to 300 million zoro's new one
was 40 of luffy's new bounty or 120
million again higher than his captain's
old one of 100 million zorro beat kaku
which is definitely not as glamorous as
beating rob lucci but kaku was good
enough to get promoted to cp 0 along
with rob lucci later on in the story and
besides the victory itself zoro since
he's the first mate it would make sense
that he would have a rising bounty to
match the increased perceived threat
level of the straw hat crew which are
now not just taking down corrupt pirates
but blatantly warring with the world
government zoro was at the paramount war
and while luffy's bounty jumped from 300
million to 400 million at some point
without him even noticing we didn't get
a new bounty for zorro it's only after
dressrosa and doflamingo's defeat that
zoro gets a new bounty of 320 million at
this point luffy's bounty is 500 million
so zoro's bounty is now over 60 of
luffy's bounty which is very cool and if
luffy didn't get that boost by doing
stuff on his own from 300 million to 400
million then the pattern of zorro's new
bounty being larger than luffy's last
would have continued but alas it didn't
technically this time because of luffy's
solo adventures before he got this
bounty zorro beat pika one of the three
top officers of the don quixote pirates
zorro could cut him easily even though
he was skilled enough to coat his whole
body in armament hockey notably pika's
bounty was 99 million before it was
frozen over 10 years ago so pretty safe
to say it's not up to date us zorro
stands at this point in the story we're
still waiting to see him get a real
challenge post timeskip and post mihawk
training and then when luffy's bounty
shot up to
billion after he was seen as the
ringleader in an attempt to assassinate
big mom and after he beat katakuri zorro
fans got some bad news of course we
couldn't expect much since zoro didn't
go to whole cake island with luffy but
what people might not have expected was
that sanji's new bounty would surpass
zoros zoro's bounty stayed the same
while vinsmoke sanji's bounty went up to
330 million furthermore former warlord
jimbei joined the crew and has a bounty
of 438 million so arzoro who used to be
viewed by the world as the first mate
and the second strongest straw hat now
actually has the fourth highest bounty
this is a great example of how bounties
are not just reflections of how strong
someone is but it still felt kind of bad
that the first mate didn't even go up in
bounty when the captain of the crew shot
up by three times i think oda did this
on purpose though to make wano in many
ways zoro's arc and his pulse wanna
bounty all the sweeter we know whole
cake was more of a sanji arc and so it
makes sense oda wanted to give him time
to shine and so it's not surprising that
he temporarily gave him a higher bounty
however as we'll see zorro is about to
reclaim the second highest bounty number
in the crew zoro fought kaido's
strongest fighter and his first mate
king which is telling in and of itself
but we can't even start there because
zoro did epic things even before that
now of course i won't go into everything
that happened in wando but i will go
into what zoro accomplished against two
yonko namely big mom and kaido first he
saved luffy from big mom's prometheus
attack by using his ability to cut fire
that he to use his own words stole from
kinemon he deflected kaido's sharp wind
blades with his own sword like it was
nothing he prepared to attack kaido with
enma using one sword style an attack
that got kaido's attention and even big
mom lost her cool completely and
screamed out and i quote look out kaido
that's no ordinary sword end quote the
attack was sharp enough to easily cut
through a horn of the giant onigishima
skull but we did not get to see what it
would have done to kaido because the
attack doesn't connect recently in fact
they animated this part and crunchyroll
published a clip called zorro makes
kaido dodge that is approaching 2
million views already not only is it a
huge deal that yonko feel like they have
to dodge your attack it is after this
that big mom says and i quote we've
underestimated them end quote how
awesome is that zorro is the one that
got her to say that answer very very
awesome zorro goes on to save luffy when
his gear 4 runs out temporarily he
attacks kaido with black rope dragon
twister and actually cuts his scale and
makes him bleed both killer and big mom
remark with surprise that zorro could
actually cut kaido's scales kaido goes
on to say the attack hurts and that must
be odin's sword now it is up to
interpretation where zoro's strength
ends and enmos begins but since enema is
currently a weapon being used by zoro it
should all be included when assessing
zoro's threat level and bounty zoro
keeps carrying luffy around and saving
him as the latter recovers eventually
the two yonko do something you'd expect
to see in fanfiction they combined their
powers to launch a yonko combo attack
they launched conquest of the sea at the
five supernova an attack that killer
says is unavoidable and what happens our
very own zorro steps up to the plate
takes the full brunt of the combo attack
so no one else has to even kid who does
not make a habit of going around and
praising people has to say it's a real
feat that zoro blocked that as if that
wasn't enough he gets up again cuts
prometheus right from under big mom some
more and chases prometheus so he can't
help big mom until kaido has to
interfere and help prometheus so he can
go and save big mom then zorro says he's
going to do something that is at the
limit of his ability at this point at
least because as we will see he will get
stronger over the course of this arc he
uses the attack dead man's game on kaido
and kaido is shocked startled that zorro
can also use conquerors haki kaido says
he's done enough and that the wound he
gave the so-called strongest creature in
the world will remain with him just like
odin's wounds did and all of that was
already epic but what's crazy is that
zoro's main fight hasn't even started
after some miracle medicine that's
actually a double-edged sword and will
make him feel way more pain afterwards
zorro gets temporarily healed enough to
fight king kaido's right hand man and
the yonko commander with the highest
known bounty at 1.39 billion i will
remind you that even though whitebeard
had the highest bounty of the yonko
while he lived and was considered the
strongest man and the closest to one
piece his right hand man marco with his
overpowered mythical zone fruit has a
lower bounty than king at
1.374 billion so king is a very big deal
based on his bounty and the fact that
he's the so-called strongest creature
strongest fighter he's also from a
god-like people that were supposed to be
very powerful but they also got wiped
out which raises some important
questions that aren't in the scope of
this video but the point for this video
is king is a monster in terms of
strength as even queen pointed out
despite all of king's power and
trickiness zorro ends up defeating him
he figures out how to work better with
enma by not trying to control the amount
of hockey he's giving it but to just let
it take as much as it wants even if that
could potentially kill zorro enma seems
to take a bunch of conquerors haki
causing people around to faint and king
to conclude that zoro 2 intends to be a
king it's logical to assume that now
zoro would be able to launch a way more
devastating attack than the one that
even yonko felt like they had to avoid
we were all hoping zoro would cut down a
dragon in this arc and we do see zoro go
up against a kind of giant magma dragon
launched by king he uses king of hell 3
sword serpent 103 mercy's dragon damn
nation yes a long name to slice through
king's attack and deliver a finishing
blow to him he even takes off one of
king's wings making it feel like the
king of hell zorro just took down a god
which is what the lunarians were
considered to be back in the day zoro
pronounces himself as the king of hell
and then has enough energy to launch a
powerful attack that sends himself back
to the floating island that's when he
presumably passes out and encounters
death himself now since we've met no
literal gods in one piece only god fruit
users my guess is that this god of the
underworld is actually enma's awakening
that's right i think zoro has a devil
fruit through enema and i explained that
in detail in my zorro already has a
devil fruit video link in the
description but it's not necessary to
know that when considering his bounty
because his bounty will be based off of
his feats here unless his devil fruit is
especially wanted by the world
government like luffy's but that's just
speculation at this point so back to the
question what will be zoro's new bounty
following his usual pattern it's safe to
say that it will be over luffy's current
bounty of 1.5 billion especially since
he just beat a godly fighter with a
bounty of 1.39 billion then there's also
the fact that before any of that he made
the yonko dodge he blocked a yonko combo
attack and even gave kaido the so-called
strongest creature in the world a
lasting wound like odyn himself for
these reasons he shall surpass both
sanji's and jinbei's new bounties and
become the person with the second
highest bounty in the crew once again if
you watch my luffy bounty video then you
know exactly why i think he'll have the
highest bounty in history after
defeating kaido understandably his first
mate the king of hell will also have a
really high one historically when
luffy's and zoro's bounties went up
together zoro reached between 40 percent
to about 60 percent of luffy's new
bounty conservatively i think luffy's
new bounty will be at least 5.75 billion
for reasons explained in the luffy's new
bounty video that would give zorro a
range from 2.3 billion to 3.45 billion
if we use the 40 to 60 percent of
luffy's new bounty rule the only problem
i have with this range at the moment is
that yonko blackbeard's own bounty is
lower than these numbers at
2.2476 billion however i think it's very
likely that blackbeard will get a
significant boost to match luffy's soon
and that would justify zoro's higher
bounty as well if on the other hand
blackbeard's bounty stays the same which
i think is unlikely then we can at least
expect zoro's bounty to be above 1.5
billion luffy's own current bounty and a
bounty higher than any other known yonko
commander's bounty this would make him a
sort of fifth emperor just like luffy is
now and i think it would be a justified
title when you think about his strength
conqueror's hockey and new king of hell
title besides the hype of having two
emperors on one crew just can't be
denied and yes i think he could very
possibly rise above mihawk's own
currently unknown bounty just as i think
luffy will rise above rogers bounty even
before he reaches the title roger
reached namely the title of pirate king
again we're looking at threat level here
and the first mate of the sun god is
much more dangerous to the world
government than a dude like mihawk who
just does his own thing on the side and
has no interest in taking down the
established order as far as we know let
me know what you think like last time if
you get his future bounty right in the
comments i shall try to include that
correct prediction in a future review or
one piece video smash that like button
if you enjoyed this video be a smashing
pirate king rather than a passing orochi
by making that youtube thumb light up
with fireworks to celebrate wano's
liberation join the nakama by hitting
that subscribe button and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates now if you
want to see why as i mentioned i
strongly believe zorro has a mythical
zone devil fruit already even though yes
i know he can swim then click the video
on screen right now and i'll see you
there